okay
what didn't mean to do that did we
hey success okay that means that chat is
wrong let me pop this one out alright
hello friends I trouble getting this
stream to stop for it seems like it's
working now I trouble getting this
stream to stop except we got it alright
hello everyone I'm Alana welcome to my
channel that's all the way longer to
figure out that I hooked and I don't
know why okay so the plan for today's
stream is that I am currently playing
doing the tunnel literally right now
playing nightmare it's pretty tough but
I'm actually not allowed to show you the
gameplay until today the review embargo
went up which means that I am allowed to
review the game but I am NOT allowed to
show you gameplay which is a huge bummer
I feel like some people will watch this
video and probably think that I'm lying
becquer should be gone should be
completely gone right yeah I fixed it
good night yeah okay people will check
that I'm lying so to the people who
assume that I'm lying I'm just gonna
tell you just look up my gamertag on
Xbox Live it's Charl honest on you'll
see that I have the achievement to do
maternal or if you're watching this live
that I am playing it currently but what
I can do is show you literally
everything makes the still is it echo no
you guys should all be fine I turned it
off there should be no echoes for anyone
problem solved
so I can answer questions for you and I
can show you everything that I'm seeing
for everyone who wants my review
impressions I just cannot show you
gameplay until the 20th for everyone
asking about multiplayer I have not had
a chance to play that at all because
multiplayer isn't out yet until the
server's alive so
you can ask me anything you like about
the campaign I am going to be playing
while we had this conversation though so
there are gonna be some bits where I
just panic or swear where have I left
off you yes I assumed there were puzzles
in this room and there we're not and
thus well just failed that platforming
bit immediately
Thank You Chico man oh hello Ethan is it
cool will it make you smile yes actually
this game is oh that's right I can add -
I'll be in the air - I forgot that I can
do that this game is extremely cool and
also I feel like I smile all the time
because some of it is just so over the
top and ridiculous that it is just
shockingly awesome it is very
challenging on nightmare like I said
that's what I'm playing on but but fast
op not you not you hell nights are just
my least favorite immediately go away go
oh I thought he was dead
alright chainsaw ah and he killed me he
killed me it was the first person I
encountered and he killed me because I
exploited a barrel on myself oh they're
the worst okay yes gunplay is very very
very good it's very similar to the first
game it's still really really really
satisfying basically anyone who likes
2016 is gonna like shooting stuff in
this game at this stage I don't have any
new weapons but I do have the flame
belch which was not in 2016 which for
anyone who doesn't know is basically
like on a controller Utah why and it
shoots flames of people from your
shoulder and they drop Alma if you use
the flame mulch because it was like the
only thing from 2016 okay he's gonna
come back again where are you jerk jerk
missed him miss him again oh the door
shut behind me that's why that's such a
problem Oh big punchy boy big punchy boy
it's fine it's fine it's fine
he's large and he's punchy okay okay
it's done it's done he's done he's done
full so yeah I don't have any new
weapons yet if you've watched any of the
trailers you will know what some of the
new weapons although
I've been pretty clear about that in the
advertising of what some of this new
stuff is it's the controller layout
different I don't think so
I think the controller that's pretty
much exactly the same how's the sound
really creepy Oh a heavy metal lead
the score is or the sound track rather
is really really similar to doom 2016
obviously it's still nickel and it rules
it's incredibly good you know here you
little punk yeah just just stay there so
I can eat you when I need to which is
going to happen at some point very soon
so yeah it's it's got it's got metal it
has some dark moments but it for the
most part is also really cynthy so
there's a lot of dramatic synth sounds
in there that make it I don't know eerie
but also just like kind of dancey hoot
some pots not commonly naturally this
dude sucks they're weak oh that was not
fair I killed him and I went to eat him
and then I stepped in electrified water
thing worth mentioning and doom eternal
there are a lot more environmental
hazards so I really like this goal I
really like the shooting I really like
the weapon variety the enemy variety is
good its doom it's always amazing I
don't like the platforming and a big
part of the issues with the platforming
you just saw master Oh Dino asked as a
platforming feel awkward and forced in
any way look I'm bad at platforming at
the best of times my biggest issue with
it if I talk about it in a way that's
objective in this game is that I feel
like it hurts the pacing of the game
there are parts in the platforming where
you're literally jumping between
floating platforms but they'll like have
a spinning fire thing like it's Super
Mario that you have to dodge while
you're platforming that stuff is the
stuff that I don't like so much it
they've created these like environmental
platforming puzzles that I just feel um
because you have to like stop and wait
for it and sometimes it'll kill you
sometimes it seems like it's impossible
to jump over I'll get through and you
just have to take the data [ __ ] I'm
sure that's not the case but it feels
like it can be really tough I don't like
that stuff in Doom so much because I
feel like it just makes you have to slow
down and think about things a lot more
than I
really ever want to in this franchise
not that the combat isn't thoughtful it
is it's they create a lot of their own
puzzles in the comment where did you go
where did you go here hey bud hey bud
you're a jerk and now you're a dead jerk
all right P you think that I'm just
lying about playing it right now what a
fraud that would be it would be very
hard to do but I have just died again in
the exact same place this is tough
nightmare it's actually look the first
like two hours are fine you're gonna be
totally fine the rest of the game is
basically if you're in a room like am
right now whether uh four big guys who
are just shooting at you and this this
particular room the doors all shut so
you can't leave and the floor is
electrified so you're really limited in
the way you can move so like running
around which is one of the most fun
things to do in doom it's just really
restricted there aren't a lot of options
for doing that but I think that's what
noting is one of the huge improvements
that they've made is a ton of variety of
mr. Damon a ton of variety to the
environments
I feel like doom 2016 which like a lot
of people managed to ignore very well
but a critics noticed it maybe a lot of
fans just didn't notice it as much is
that the game is pretty repetitive oh I
just got a glitch there that's actually
the first time I've seen that my first
glitch baby's first glitch okay where
are you I was getting shot at and I
don't know where it went
okay edemen hey but hey pipe a bud
yeah the first team had or 2016 not
doing one basically just had a corridor
and then a room where enemies would
shoot you just over and over and over
again and I think also because you know
there were only two different hell night
showed up and killed me I didn't even
see him didn't even see him show up just
just dead immediately this room's gonna
be tough gonna be real tough it was
corridors in the rooms that you would
shoot in and that was a yeah only only
two environments think that got really
repetitive I think not even that badly
to the game's detriment it was just an
obvious room for improvement
they have improved that in this game
environments feel a lot more different
but also just the gameplay scenarios
that you approach in each environment
feels very different and like this room
that I'm in right now is a puzzle that I
have to figure out playing on nightmare
naturally you're gonna dial up foster
when you're trying to figure out these
puzzles but it really does it's not just
to shoot up doom it's not just a shooter
it is absolutely a puzzle game
rendezvous said for someone who is a
totally familiar with doom should I try
the 2016 game or is this one good to
just jump in on you'll be fine just
jumping in on doom eternal but I would
highly recommend playing doom 2016 it's
short you could finish it really quickly
I finished it within 24 hours earlier
this year but you do not need to
I also saw someone in the chat they
asked if I'm more of a doom or an animal
crossing person I am much more of a
doing person by like a mile but I like
Animal Crossing too I just there's no
way that I'll be as passionate about a
game like Animal Crossing as I am about
a game like doom doom 1 is one of my
favorite games ever doom 2016 I would
take over a new leaf but I definitely
like both come on buddy you're so close
come on I know I know you are one more
one more come on
thank you this is gonna be real tough
but hey uh doom being challenging is fun
to me
yeah he's done full we gotta watch out
for that other he'll night he showed up
and just kill me I think it just
happened again I didn't even see him
I didn't even Tevan see him I was like
we gotta watch out for him
he's gonna kill me why was he where did
he show up what do I feel is the
shooting the platforming slush puzzle
ratio well like I said I think Doom is a
puzzle game just as much as it is a
first-person shooter so the puzzles of
frequent environmental puzzles a
frequent platforming there is more
shooting than platforming by a wide
margin it's not that there is too much
platforming my issue is with the way
that the platforming breaks up the
combat which is fantastic and also like
there are a lot of other things that I
really like like I really like the world
design this game has these really cool
set pieces so just place his way you see
environments whether is like to
like giant enemies frozen in battle with
one another it's really pretty the lore
is fantastic this is way more story have
even 2016 they're a little like really
really really strong suits but I feel
like all of those stroke those strong
suits just get broken up by like I said
platforming where you don't get to see
the world because often they have like a
wall that's intentionally carved out for
you to jump and grab that has to kind of
be away from the other cool things that
you look at and there's no platforming
that's organically just like built into
the cool things it's always like a
monkey like handlebar type thing or it's
a yeah wall that's like clearly got
scratches on it it feels like their
approach to level design in that regard
is what a lot of games were doing a long
time ago where like now you've got you
know God of War where the they've got
even the way that the platforms are
shown yeah didn't even get a hit on me
that time big jerk even the way the
platforms are shown ties into the story
because somebody made those platforms
for you oh okay I can't even get out of
my face same guy I need to figure figure
out when he arrives this is insane
it's a nightmare if you will he just
shows up and kills me before I even see
him we're gonna have to do something
about that for the record
chat I will only be answering doom
eternal related questions right now I'm
sure I'll do another stream where you
can just talk to me go talk to me about
whatever you guys want but you know we
want to play my play I can give you that
but yeah I did want to get on my
positives out of the way I feel like
I've mostly done that this game is very
good it's it's so cool it's really
pretty it's it's surprisingly colorful
for doom my camera's just gone out of
focus why have you done that there you
go
I love the combat I love the weapon
variety I love the enemy variety the
glory kill animations and death
animations in general are so cool its
explosive and fun I just really like the
world and the lore this time around they
they don't like shove it in your face
it's not too much but you know there are
more cutscenes they're all like specific
enemies you're trying to get that you
have interactions with who
real jerks you know the part of a
council where it's doomed 2016 law was a
little bit more reading focus this is a
little bit more involved the only thing
I don't like is the platforming and even
then it's not really an issue with how
it controls I think it controls just
fine
my issue with it is just that I feel
like it hurts the pacing I feel like it
slows things down it takes me out of you
know this high-octane action game where
did you go Oh at times where I don't
necessarily want no you don't know you
don't know you don't know Ilana oh I
ruined it that's such a bummer that was
my own fault I couldn't get back up
there we go
that's good we just got a hell night and
a khaki demon in okay so now this all
the hell Knights gonna show up and he's
gonna kill you
because you know we will well there is
good okay okay it's fine it's fine
we saw him where did he go where did he
go [ __ ] I don't know where he is
well there's too much other stuff in
there you go okay there's too much other
stuff in the room that I can't like stop
running oh there you go just stay where
you are but just stay wait you're not
killing me again it's not gonna happen
I'm not taking that yeah I got him in
the foot I'm gonna need you to die
I may need you to die oh I got stuck on
something that's not great that's not
great but there's no one I can't eat
right now to get my health back did I
get him no [ __ ] again at least I saw him
that time because everyone's on this
electric floor I can't eat them so
basically on night night you can only
take like two three hits before you die
[Music]
it's gonna be tough
but for whatever reason something about
the combat loop of doom like I said
because it acts like a puzzle I never
get frustrated so I find it really
intense and stressful especially in the
rooms that have like a manky bus and a
hell night and a pinky it gets really
really stressful but I never find it
frustrating this the struggle for me is
never frustrating have you played it
copy each other oh you said he also
reviewed it it felt cumbersome at
certain points normal when trying to get
collectibles I guess you could say that
the platforming is is a break from the
fighting because it literally is I just
don't want that break I think
Jason acid earlier in the stream I'm not
allowed to show you the gameplay that's
under embargo thank you unique technique
I hope I said that right
same to you Yankee blue I'm not allowed
to show you the gameplay as it is
currently embargoed you can see gameplay
on Thursday it's when we're allowed to
show you but the review embargo went up
today so I thought I would do a sort of
review stream to just like answer any
questions anyone has about it so I'm not
allowed to show you what's my favorite
weapon my dude it's a BFG absolutely a
PFG
I know that's cheating but come on now
the weapon that I think I use the most
where are you damn it both in this ad in
2016 is the combat shotgun which I
really like to add the yeah we go that's
it
what is it they're kind of like it's an
explosive ability that you can add that
is exactly what I'm using right now
that's how you take out the Cacodemons
you sort of shoot it right into their
little mouths which I will say is like
the only thing about this nightmare mode
that I find too forgiving I'm like well
really I was pretty far away they just
scooped it up into their mounts I guess
they have big mouths but it seems like
it's a little bit too easy to do damn
died because I got caught on a door this
one's gonna take me up a hot minute as
the hot world come into play the point
you're in yes Jeff the hub world does
have law but it's it's not for law I
imagine it'll come into the into play as
I get further into the story
thank you go skill right now I feel like
it's a little bit pointless it's there
for upgrades there's like a training
rounds where you can test new weapons
you do get some weapons there's pickups
I think I almost recently got like a
freeze bomb free screen a type thing
sorry that's what I showed in the
gameplay that I already have up on my
channel which was from February but
that's you know it's the same game that
you're looking at well that I'm looking
at right now it's very very similar to
that gameplay if you want to see
gameplay that's the early stages of the
game
good so right now this music is so
cynthy it's just like this droning
dramatic synth sound it's come on come
on
see I just died there because of
platforming I just didn't grab the ledge
when I wanted it to and I feel like I
had that problem in 2016 a fair amount -
I'm like I'm trying to grab this ledge
over and over never again and I can't
and I died but again would most people
are probably not gonna play on nightmare
because it is nightmarishly hot in big
rooms like this where there are 15
enemies I consider these like boss fight
rooms basically which doom still has a
lot of it but I feel like this scattered
out a little bit more maybe less
frequent than they were in 2016 in favor
of having um just just a lot more
variety
this one is literally arena style a
circle with a lot of big enemies in it
that are just taking you out at once
that is particularly focused and hard
but they have loads of stuff in between
which is really nice John Lopez said
thoughts on the unmake ax I don't know
what the unmake ax is is that a
character or something I'm not sure what
you what you're referring to this so I
cannot answer that question
oh if it's a character wow do I have a
habit of forgetting character names I
got criticized for that when I told
everyone Deadly Premonition was my
favorite game which I finished multiple
times but I don't remember many
characters names nope
oh you don't just hell nights man like
honestly virtually any fight where
there's none of these guys in it I'm
like cool can't wait and having a great
time I can't handle these dudes they
just destroy me too fast oh that was a
glitch - having some performance issues
in this one for the first time all
rights get that kaki demon let's shoot
you let's kill you something fun about
this fight is that I'm looking at it in
a really specific way where I'm like
okay I'm gonna shoot you with this and
then I'm gonna turn around and I'm gonna
shoot you with this while you recover
from that and I'm just kind of bouncing
between that over and over and over
again which is um just that balance is
really fun I think that was lucky got
the second whole night for the first
time now the rest of this room is a
breeze like none of the rest of this is
gonna be hard for me at all if we get
him in and eat him I ain't got any
problems but I can't I just can't get
anyone that I'm shooting who's on the
ground
yeah did it just need if that second
goddamn helmet okay I'm gonna check the
room for collectibles but it doesn't
look like there are any we will take a
look no it's empty it's empty for sure
I'm aware you can't see the game I'm
currently playing an xbox one X yeah but
I have also been playing on PC and have
have played on PC and I should mention
performance is great on both I have not
been able to play on ps4 just because
they weren't giving out that many codes
so when normally oh maybe it is the
right way in the room just looks the
same I seems unlikely no I think that's
yeah here we go so yes it is it is good
to go on every platform basically which
is also maybe I think I'm just about to
leave this level I am thank you I
appreciate that Baker let's go back to
back to hub
the game is pretty I will have you know
you are you're gonna want to play Geoff
oz have you played through on an easy
difficulty if so how long did this area
take you competitive nightmare I haven't
finished it on easy difficulty I've been
playing right now the whole time but I
have previously played it on Hut me
plenty an ultra violence at different
events nightmare is a lot hotter and one
thing that I really want to mention that
I think is awesome
is that ultra nightmare has different PC
specs from every other difficulty
because basically like on nightmare you
take a lot more damage enemies attack
you more and a lot faster so ultra
nightmare the game is just like so much
more high octane in terms of like what's
being thrown at you that you have to
have a better PC to even run it which is
awesome I think it's very very very cool
confirm it doom 2016 an eternal circles
of doom 64 I'm not allowed to answer
that question unfortunately no ghost
skill I did intentionally jump into
nightmare this time I've been playing
doom 1 on I know I've done this before
who are you kidding I love that I keep
running into combat environments why
enemies a shooting each other it's cool
they'll like just fight each other on
this particular planet dead don't know
what kill me
what did I what was oh yeah I've been
playing through doom one on nightmare
for the past like yeah just slowly every
now and then when I'm waiting for
something to download I pick up a level
or whatever
I like doom on hard because again I look
at this game is like I go in and I lone
and once I've learned the room then I
know how to survive it's not just that
it's hard it's it's a lot more than that
so and it enemies really don't take that
long to kill like once you not all of
them at least like pinkies are really
tough but like a manky boss is easy like
some of them a khaki demon is too easy I
think like that
is a legitimate complaint that I have
but once you you you figure out like
okay that one dies quickly so I will use
that as food while I take out the big
guy I don't have time for your [ __ ] mate
too big too jumpy big jumpy chunky boy
yes got him I should probably change so
someone huh I need some ammo yeah once
you figure out what the big guys in the
room are and like what I think that was
probably another hell night just got
killed in the back I didn't see who did
it yeah then you can start taking out
the big guys slowly and use the other
guys to eat and I like that loop a lot I
think it's really really fun and so with
this game be a good training manual for
people who are headed to hell should I
learn to read and buy a Bible well this
is hell on earth
that's what do maternal is all about so
not good for you if you're headed to
hell not that that is an extremely
present in the game but a lot of this is
focused - there's also like I think I
can talk about it I showed it in my
gameplay there's an ice planet oh there
are just just in general ton of ton of
combat Osorio environment variety that
was not present in the first one died
again just so fast just so fast
I do call glory kills eating yes
cuz I am I'm getting their health and
doom 2016 hell nights became child's way
once you had a super shotgun and gas you
just swap between the two alternating
shots the super shotgun is still gonna
be your best friend against them I think
but I feel like I was gonna say that
maybe the upgrades you get in Doom
eternal is slow up but that's actually
probably not true I think it's just that
the game is longer so it feels like
they're a little bit slower or a little
bit more paced out but like for example
even if you've seen it in all of the
gameplay videos you don't stop with I
should eat in him you don't start with
the
the flame bulge this is one enemy type
that has this thing that they shoot that
looks like like candy what get out of
here with you damn candy nope that this
is so quick thank you I was only gonna
do this for half an hour so does anyone
else have any other review related
questions but stuff that you can just
google I'm probably not gonna focus too
much on that does the difficulty gonna
hurt me plenty let you enjoy it it seems
very difficult so much enemies I think
most people should probably play on huh
be plenty the way I'm playing is very
specific to what I enjoy which is that I
I like it being super punishing I think
most people that's what I would
recommend that they play on again ultra
nightmare I'm never gonna touch that I
don't nobody got time for that
come on come on
glad I got that upgrade I got an upgrade
so that I can trigger glory kills from
further away that's I just upgraded that
I didn't didn't think of how important
it would be that when I started getting
it I'm like very glad I got it it's
super helpful that's the thing that I
really like to sort of present
occasionally in June 2016 but portals
are a little bit more common in this
game like just environments that have
portals so that you can jump between one
area and another is everyone dead that
seems suspicious I don't believe you
that you will hey bud try and swing at
me oh I love a goddamn hell night knit
with an environment mad easy to kill you
just keep running at you like a big
buffoon it's the circles that get me I
don't think I have a shotgun and I need
that for the Cacodemons found a secret
very cool
yeah the secrets is super fun but they
always happen that's like you know doom
one DNA but just worth noting they are
really helpful so if you're gonna play
this game it is
much more worth spending the time
looking around environments to try to
find a secret if you can than it is to
just try and finishing it quickly
because they help you all what a lot of
them willing to - upgrades and stuff
like that so yeah I highly recommend
keeping an eye out for him
alrighty we did it that was a big one
so only gonna get worse from here I can
feel it I can feel it what's my favorite
change from 2016
I think the flame belch is a really good
change but no it is mostly the way that
they've changed the approach to the
world just that you jump between so many
different things to do whether it's
solving a puzzle which can be like a
platforming puzzle or an environmental
puzzle like killing a certain amount of
enemies or whatever finding a secret -
walking through a corridor where there's
some story - meeting a character -
climbing of the giant Colossus they're
just a lot of different things to do
can I have not had access to battle mode
that is not up yet
yeah for everyone who's asking about
game play again I'm not a lot of show to
you but there is already gameplay video
on my channel so no spin me since you
described combat almost as a puzzle in
itself if you died enter him and try
again does it spawn the same enemies as
last time yes
in the same order and in the same
location that's why I consider it to be
more of a puzzle it's it's about you
approaching it figuring out where they
come from and how to get them basically
it's just the most jak doom guy yet he's
pretty jacked house hunting for secrets
work for pacing in 2016 it kind of slow
it does slow you down yeah but you have
to like make the effort to do it and I
don't mind hunting for the secrets
because like that's a puzzle I find fun
whereas the platforming I don't really
find fun it's something other games have
been doing for a long time so it just
doesn't really mean very much to me
Rhys wild that's a good question to end
on we said three would doom eternal
review okay only three woods you say
hectic brutal satisfying those would be
my big three it's extremely hectic in
terms of like frantically running around
environments it's brutal in terms of the
tone the world the soundtrack
totally just super brutal and satisfying
in terms of just level design story
progression I think is satisfying the
way it it ties in to other things as
satisfying finding puzzles secrets is
satisfying so yeah there's a lot of
stuff that I that I really really really
liked honestly the only thing I have
issues with is the platform and a couple
of performance issues which I remember
seeing in the preview that I've just
seen a few of here where like I'll get
stuck on something I won't be able to
climb something that I should be able to
climb because my angle is just a tiny
bit off or
and enemy like glitches on something
basically but load screens on both PC
and Xbox are really really short I've
tried both super quick it's a really
accessible game it's super fun
like I highly recommend it it's it's
fantastic so yeah I just kinda wanted to
make the stream to answer as much as I
could I don't know if it's going to game
pause overall performance is great some
minor issues game is very hard
yes but depends on what difficulty you
play on so it's up to you and I think
that's pretty much it I didn't want to
do this one for too long just wanted to
give you guys sort of my impressions
while playing the game so thank you guys
watching if you have any more questions
you can tweet them at me I can answer
them we'll leave them in the comments on
the the video that I'll leave up on my
youtube channel so you're welcome to do
that too and have fun everyone bye doom
play it on Friday it's kind of the best
alright yes